so let me uh get into the good news the
good news the white pill I want you all
to feel much better with this report CNN
had Chris Licht admits layoffs on the
horizon as anxious staffers Grill him
during Town Hall huge nerves oh no CNN's
going to be laying off more people guys
uh oh what's what's this story from
deadline Vice Media cuts around two
percent of digital news and Publishing
staff as part of latest consolidation
efforts that's what they call it
consolidation I call it the end of the
Old Guard Vice was supposed to be the IG
New Media but they went woke so fast Now
CNN is crumbling down and I want to
stress this as it pertains mostly to CNN
Donald Trump has announced he's running
for president
CNN has been brought to heal is in
shambles Twitter is under the control of
Elon Musk
it's going to be a Donald Trump rematch
but without the establishment cultural
Powers at the level they were in the
past several election Cycles so should
be interesting to say the least but um I
know Luke is the is the most sad about
CNN's layoffs I know I need a violin
here to to reel in this moment here I
can't believe you know we can't have so
much great where else are we going to
get the memes from where else are we
going to get all the inspiration hold on
there that's actually true I know that
you weren't kidding we need the
opposition yeah if there's no CNN we
need the hacks we're not the hacks I
mean what are we going to do I guess I
can make memes about about Luke you can
make me he'll be the only one else in
media yeah I'll play the antagonistic
idiot for you but the narrative machine
is breaking at a time when when we're
going to see Donald Trump come back the
The Narrative machine is going full
swing they're saying he's a drag on the
party he's not they're saying there was
no Red Wave there was and they're
they're trying to to blame Donald Trump
and say he's got to go when in reality
what happens is Media manipulation and
ballot harvesting the reason and I'll
stress this point too there was a Red
Wave five million more Republican votes
than Democrat votes sorry that's just a
reality just because it wasn't in the
right places doesn't mean that there was
no Red Wave but I get it if you're
arguing Red Wave meant a wave of
Victories across the country agreed if
you're arguing that Republicans turned
out in massive numbers then they did it
just didn't hit the places that mattered
most did you see how the New York Post
covered Trump's announcement uh-huh they
put it on page 26 and their title was
Florida man makes announcement that's
how they covered Donald Trump they're
all terrified of this man they're saying
look at the same time the New York Post
New York Post I mean they're the ones
that broke the hunter Biden story sure
sure but at the same time that these
media Outlets are claiming Donald Trump
is done and it's over they're also
claiming it's a dangerous
insurrectionist who must be stopped at
all costs
we get it I see you they're terrified
and they're just they're that here's
what happened the first time around
CNN and these other woke Outlets went
for the Trump is evil Trump is evil
everybody stop stop stop
well all that did was embolden Trump now
they're trying to play it cool Trump
he's so six years ago he's not cool you
like Trump here's all I am that's not
gonna work either when Trump gets on
stage and then starts going after these
people calling them out people are gonna
laugh at it
I think that even though we see CNN
MSNBC these different Outlets sort of
sizing down
uh even as long as they can still get
their message out and there's no or
there's little competition against that
message then then mission accomplished
because they can put out a narrative
they can put out a story or they can put
out some sort of Spin and then go on all
the socials where there's a lot of
conservatives and people that are no
longer allowed to voice back and so
therefore their narrative their lies
their or their truth depending on how
you look at it is able to take root in
that way and you know I don't see these
like CNN actually making a pivot towards
let's actually
um tell the truth I mean maybe now every
now and again just for just just for fun
they they will or maybe just water it
down so it's kind of like Fox News where
you're kind of thinking you're watching
the right you know the the the the the
actual news but you're not yeah yeah
it's going to be interesting I just want
to make a really quick point because uh
there is some uh rumors that that CNN
viewership did go up during the Trump
announcement and if you look at CNN's
viewership it's pretty much reliant on
Donald Trump so now will the corporate
media get a Revival from Trump or will
they ignore him how will this play out I
don't know two million four hundred and
thirty thousand views
CNN as compared to 5 million one hundred
fifty seven thousand on Fox as compared
for last night yeah for the Trump these
are last night ratings yes one million
one hundred and twenty seven thousand
for Newsmax and this is CNN's owned by
Warner Brothers Discovery so it's I
think at this point which is owned by
BlackRock State Street you know
International marketing firms and
investment firms and I think that
they're using it as like a form of
impact investment at this point the CNN
news brand they're just going to use it
to to spread their ideology and uh let
the company be damned like they'll let
it go under and dissipate they got
bought out you know I don't know when
uh 12 this year Warner Brothers bought
them this year this is going to be
interesting do you see Trump giving a
Revival to the media press one in the
chat press two if you if you don't see
that happening because I'm curious what
the people think out there
because I I don't know it could go
either way here
so this is uh was it last night
CNN had a total of 2.43 million viewers
at 9pm and it had 5.157 Wagner on MSNBC
had 1.8 uh so let's do this let's go
back
and then we'll take a look at uh if
adweek loads I don't know the website
never loads Monday to see what their
ratings are maybe it won't won't
actually allow us to see it we'll see
what happens but I'd love to compare
there's a lot of ones in the chat a lot
of people take a look at this the the
the views were double the day before
um the views were half for Hannity and
for uh
for for CNN so
I I have a feeling that CNN is going to
lean back into Trump stuff but I don't
know if if uh ratings is what's going to
sell for them I think that they're using
it as impact investment they're they're
looking at it as a loss they don't want
money out of it they just want to change
people's minds to get them to support
the New World Order so just really
quickly when uh the news came about that
missile strike in Poland I automatically
had social media up but just to be just
to be aware of everything I was like let
me just turn on the TV see what they're
saying and I went on Fox and on Fox
during this key important breaking news
moment they had an anchor celebrating
his own birthday talking about his
achievements right I went on MSNBC and
they were talking about we need
retribution we need to act right now and
then I went on went on to CNN and they
were talking about can you can you guess
Donald Trump in January 6th during this
key moment and they weren't breaking the
news they weren't talking about what was
happening in Ukraine in Europe with
Russia with this larger War at the G20
they were talking about Trump and
January 6th uh and I'm like really this
this is this is what I'm tuning into
this is insane I get more reliable news
on Twitter than I do of course the
corporate media I'm also looking at
these layoffs and that I I've been
noticing the last week Amazon is about
to lay off 10 000 employees and that'll
laid off 11 11 000 Twitter laid off half
their staff which is a slightly
different situation well it's it's a
shrinkage of the economy right now
because of what we did with for the
covid money print scam or scheme
whatever you want to call it
um and now we're starting to see like 10
000 people what in the heck that's a lot
of uh there was a bunch of corporate
layouts were you guys following all
these corporate layoffs in the last over
the last week well I mean CNN and vice
CNN voice is there Amazon I'm trying to
get a list of a meta oh you know what I
really want to know about this is a
little off topic but Larry and Sergey
the guys that created Google and now
alphabet where are they what are they
doing they are in control of the world's
largest media apparatus ever created
and they were supposedly a free speech
Advocates but are they just gone full
technocrat like where are they full-time
no crap probably living on an island
somewhere in the largest giant mansion
ever created with the smart home and
they're just like whatever I like to
imagine that the rich people built a
city underwater called Rapture and
they're all experimenting with uh Gene
editing technology you guys you bought
YouTube man yeah but Ian they've been
down in this underwater city for so long
and the gene splicing has mutated people
and the society collapsed so they're
living in this is not a video game that
Bioshock is one of the best games ever
yeah it's a video game but yeah it's the
general idea is um Galt Gulch
the powerful Elites basically leave
let's let the system rot because it's
gone astray and people want stupid
things and then the people who are
productive dip out I don't blame them
this is what we're this is idiocracy we
you know we talked about this the other
day when we talked about the Exodus from
cities think about all of the people who
fled New York or California because of
the coveted policies or whatever that's
a brain drain on these places the most
productive people are moving to Texas in
Florida Joe Rogan Elon Musk Texas so
they're going to bring all of that
Enterprise and Ingenuity into these
other states the economy of those States
is going to Skyrocket it's going to
create this new I don't know I don't
know what you'd call it but um
effectively like a a business rush
there's going to be new opportunities
new money new inventions new tech and
these other blue states are going to
turn into wastelands they've lost their
their top talent where are you Michael
and where do you see things going
financially as well
well obviously there's a massive
um
contraction happening
um I was just out for the past month and
a half all across the country
um all over really
um
and and and you see it everywhere the
the the hurt the the economic hurt
whether it's gas prices or people just
going to the supermarkets
um
I don't see us going in a good
uh Direction economically
because of the system and because of
what we're not doing
um as well as the things that we're
doing I don't have a positive outlook on
on the economy unless and I know that
that's what we everybody's trying to do
is get people into these positions of
power that can then create a system and
make the changes that we need to make so
that the economy does work for everyone
because I think the way to peace and
prosperity and and happiness and joy and
good things are is when people are happy
and productive and they're doing things
and you know pursuing happiness pursuing
the things that they want to pursue when
you have people that are trying to
figure out how am I going to feed my
kids how am I going to keep the lights
on it's going to get cold in the winter
wonder how I'm gonna heat my house that
really takes away from the things in in
life individually and and collectively
that then create a society where we can
start to gain those levels in the
simulation and and get higher up in this
instead of just
everything burning up and breaking down
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time